il faut dire un mot du rapport qui a été
rédigé par un organisme dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler qui s'appelle
le club de rome
1972 un rapport scientifique alimente
les discussions sur les plateaux télé le
rapport milloz l'idée centrale du
rapport est que contrairement à ce que
l'on a pu penser jusqu'à présent la
terre est limitée
l'alerté lancée la planète est en danger
à l'origine du rapport le club de rome
un groupe de réflexion international
réunissant scientifiques économistes et
industriels à cette époque la société de
consommation explose et la crise
pétrolière se dessine la croissance
industrielle et économique inquiète
c'est à la demande d'un groupe
multinational de scientifiques et
industrielles le club de rome que les
chercheurs du massachusetts institute of
technology 2ème haïti se sont mis au
travail ils ont fait parler l'ordinateur
et grâce à lui ont pu établir un modèle
dynamique des activités humaines à
l'échelle planétaire
cette étude a mis en relief les
tendances les plus inquiétants de notre
développement et leurs interactions pour
les auteurs du rapport les conclusions
sont claires dévorée par sa soif de
croissance l'humanité court à sa perte
aurelio pétillent et le fondateur du
club de rome pour lui il y avait urgence
à agir c'est ce cet équilibre entre
populations production ressources
espaces disponibles qu'il faut trouver
les trouver assez rapidement sinon si
nous ne faisons pas ça nos fils nos no
no no no
les prochaines générations devront payer
notre imprévoyance notre égoïsme pour
faire face à l'épuisement des ressources
et à l'augmentation démographique
planétaire aurelio pitcher y avait une
solution la régulation des naissances le
plus grave c'est la surpopulation du
monde maintenant il faut prendre
conscience et connaissance des nouvelles
réalités si nous ne sommes pas capables
de faire ça alors je pense que
souffrance humaine sérum parce qu'un
fini vision pessimiste de l'avenir qui
ne convainc pas tout le monde à l'époque
parmi les sceptiques le ministre de
l'économie français valéry giscard
d'estaing alors les théoriciens de cette
doctrine en tire une conclusion 5 qui
est il faut arrêter la croissance je ne
suis pas un partisan de ces théories
pourtant cinquante ans plus tard ces
théories sont plus que jamais à l'ordre
du jour il n'y a désormais plus aucune
place pour le doute selon le dernier
rapport du giec pour agir c'est
maintenant ou jamais
[Musique]